The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: All right.
So let's start with a quick
introduction my name is
Gabriel, Gabriel Sanchez.
I am a lecturer and
research associate
in the transit lab at MIT.
We're over at Building 1.
My office is in room 1235.
And that's where
office hours are
going to be every Tuesday
at 11:00 or by appointment.
Send me an email--
can you hear me at the back?
Yeah?
If you want, you can
send me an email.
And we can arrange
for office hours
if you have any questions
about homework or anything
about lecture.
So speaking of
OpenCourseWare, you
should have all
seen some notices up
as you came into the room.
We're going to be recording
the class this semester.
So that we can share
it with the world.
So I think you're all
good-looking people.
But if you are anxious or
nervous about being recorded,
there a back burner
over there won't be--
it'll be a blind
spot in the cameras.
Any recording of your faces
will be completely incidental.
That's not our intention.
It's not to record you.
The camera is pointing at me.
And we're going to
look at the slides.
If I move over to the
sideboard and you are a,
then you'll be recorded.
So please don't let
that intimidate you.
Participate as much as
possible and make people
feel that they're in
the classroom with you.
So we're welcoming
people for years
to come to this class,
people in the future.
Let's look at the syllabus.
This class meets Tuesdays
and Thursdays at 4:00.
You're here.
You found the room, 2131.
The final exam date and
time will be announced.
I usually have the final
exam in the same room
as we have lecture.
So if it's available,
we'll have it here.
The time and date is pending.
Office hours, as I said
earlier, are on Tuesdays
at 11:00 or by appointment.
You can send me an email.
You have my email up at the top.
You probably read the
course description.
So I'll skip that.
And we'll get into
that when we start
talking about introduction
for today's class.
We'll have five problem sets.
And they will carry a weight of
65% of the grade split evenly.
A fifth of that
65% is going to be
for each of these assignments
if that makes sense.
And then 35% of the total cost
grade will be the final exam.
There's just one final exam.
There won't be a partial.
And regarding attendance,
I'm not grading attendance.
But I do consider it,
especially if you're
in the fence at the
end of the class.
I'll be more generous
pushing you up
if you have
participated actively.
Now, let's look at the course
schedule on the second page.
In this class, we
have 26 lectures.
They're numbered
on the left column.
And they are divided
into four themes.
The first three lectures
are introductory.
So it's a theme of introduction
to public transportation
systems.
Lectures 4 through 12 are on
data analysis and modeling.
So you'll see that we cover
data analysis techniques
and different models--
cost modeling and
ridership forecasting.
Lectures 13 through 15 are on
service planning and operations
planning.
That's when we get
into scheduling
and you really
understand what it
takes to plan transit service
and what drives costs.
And then after that,
all the remaining topics
are on the more general
theme of strategy, policy,
and other advanced topics.
So that's to round out what
you know by that point.
If we have changes to the
schedule such as a snow day,
we will publish that on Stellar.
OK, on the back, we have
a little description
of what OpenCourseWare is.
I think most of you should
know what OpenCourseWare is.
It's an online system
to share classes at MIT
with the rest of the world.
And so we're
recording as I said.
And the spot on the
back is the blind spot
if you want to avoid being
recorded incidentally.
Normally, no matter where you
sit, you won't be recorded.
Maybe you're the back
of your head might be
but not your face.
In terms of readings, we
have a few relevant books.
Some of them are reports.
And they are posted on Stellar.
Please raise your hand if
you don't know about Stellar
or not familiar
with the Stellar.
We have one, OK.
Are you from-- you're
not from MIT, right?
OK, so send me an email so
that I can give you access
to the site.
It's a website where we
share all the materials
and homeworks and such things.
So some of these books such
as The Transit Capacity
and Quality of Service Manual
is already posted there.
So it's a PDF you can
download to your computer.
There are also three books.
I'm not expecting anyone to
read these books or to buy them.
I brought them.
Please pass them around.
If you're interested because
you really like this topic,
you can go ahead and buy them
or borrow them from somewhere.
I think they're
in the libraries.
So you can also get them there.
So just how you can
flip through them
and have a look if you want.
But as I said,
we're not expecting
that you read them or buy them.
They're not really necessary
for any of the homework
that we're going to have.
So it's supplementary.
And finally, an acknowledgment.
This course is Professor
Nigel Wilson's course.
And I lecture it.
But most of the material
that we have in this course
is provided by him and
follows of a long history
of teaching 1258 in the way that
we are teaching it here at MIT.
It was his creative
process that led to this.
Do you have any questions
about the syllabus
before we get started
with the class?
Any questions about
what we plan to cover
or what the style of
this course will be?
OK.
In terms of homework, the
first one, which I passed out,
is for you to work
on individually.
If you don't have a copy
of that, please get--
it's one sheet in the front.
And that's due a week from now.
It'll be your St.
Valentine's present for me.
And please let me know
if you have questions.
It should be a
straightforward homework.
There's a reading that you do.
And it's on Stellar.
And then without
reading, you should
be able to answer the
questions on this homework.
After this, you will have
some assignments that
are worked in pairs
or in bigger teams,
especially ones regarding data
collection and service planning
and operations planning.
So there's going to
be a lot of teamwork.
And I will send the survey.
I will post an announcement on
Stellar, which should reach you
by email, regarding a
survey where I ask you
in more detail
about your interests
and your background on
things like programming
and optimization,
which are things
that are not necessary
for taking this course.
But at some point,
they might bring
in interesting perspective
in the homeworks.
So I try to
distribute that talent
evenly across the
groups doing homeworks
so that everybody has a chance
of getting that perspective.
But don't worry if you
don't have that experience,
it won't affect you.
All right.
We're ready to start.
Do you have any questions
before we start today's lecture?
OK, so today's
lecture is the sort
of introduction to the course.
And we'll talk about the
current status and recent trends
of the public
transportation industry
here in the US, what influences
those trends and that status.
We'll have a critical
assessment of where we are
and the things that
we'd have to do
to increase the role of
public transportation
if that's what we want.
We'll talk about
arguments put forth
in support of public
transport and, in some cases,
rebuttals for them.
We'll talk what future
influences and ingredients
for future success.
Let's get right into it.
If we look at the transit
industry right now.
We have ridership patterns that
are increasing but moderately.
And they remain small.
Public transportation in
the US and North America
remains a small percent
of the total mode share.
Because most people travel
through using private autos
or modes like that.
Now, there's a strong
financial support
from our local
government, local state,
and federal in terms of
funding and providing funding
from tax revenue.
There has been
significant growth
in the number of new rail
starts in the past 25 years--
so new systems, new metro
systems, new light rail
systems.
And we'll talk
about why that is,
that it has to do with
the funding structure here
in the US.
There's been also
major rebuilding
of many older systems.
And that has to do with the
same funding incentives, which
is not necessarily
true in Europe
and other parts of the world.
Institutional innovation
has been quite slow.
But there's a
growing recognition
that, with the new modes of
transportation and where we are
and where we're going
in terms of trends,
we might need to rethink some
of that institutional structure.
And we'll get into that
later in the course.
So if we look at the
trends in modal split--
that's one of the first
things that I mentioned--
over the last,
say, four decades,
we see that auto is steadily
above 80% in the whole US.
So it is the dominant
mode for transportation.
And these are journey to work.
So this is the morning
commute to work from home.
Transit, on the
other hand, floats
right around between 2% and
3%, sometimes a bit lower.
And what we can see
is that in the 1990s--
in 1990 and 1995--
you see a slight dip in
public transportation use
and some increase
in private auto use.
And since then, we
started a recovery
towards lower auto use
and slightly higher
public transportation use.
Walking is the same pattern
as transit and bicycling
also similar.
But these are very
small components--
very, very small modes.
References for this, if you want
more details, are listed below.
In terms of ridership
in absolute terms,
you see that, in the
last four decades,
we've had an increase,
so especially in rail.
So if you look at the
dark teal right here,
most of this increase that
we see in the last 10 years
is from rail.
These are only public
transportation trips.
So having rail
here in that we're
talking about metro and
subway, we have bus here
and then [AUDIO OUT]
all other modes.
But it's all other
transit modes.
So make sure that
you understand that.
We're talking about light rail.
We're talking about
ferries, other forms
of public transportation,
not private auto.
But this is in
absolute terms, not
in relative terms in
terms of mode share.
If we look at recent
trends from 2004 to 2014,
we see an increase in
public transportation
that is quite high,
especially when you compare it
to the population increase.
And when you compare it to
the change in highway vehicle
miles of travel in the
US at national level.
So we see a 2% increase
in highway vehicle miles
traveled and about 9%
increase in population
and about 21% increase in
public transportation use.
So it's been
especially recently.
And you can see a dip due to the
most recent economic recession,
but a pretty healthy
recovery after that.
And part of what's
driving this is
that the population is
increasing, of course,
as it always has.
But especially the urban
population is increasing.
This happening all around the
world, not just in the US.
In fact, it's happening
more outside of the US
than it is here in the US.
If you look at
the UN projections
for population increase, most
of the population increase
in the world for
the next decades
is projected to occur in urban
centers and in Metropolis.
So in fact, the population
change estimates
say that rural
population is actually
going to decrease by 2050.
So not only are
you going to have
the natural rate of
population increase
that mostly will
happen in cities,
you're also going to have people
moving away from rural areas
into cities.
And why is that?
Well, why are people
moving into cities?
And why is this
happening more and more?
We have some volunteers?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Sure.
So access to jobs is a big one.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: OK,
so it's more than that.
But yeah.
So there are more cultural
activities and sports
and museums and all sorts of--
MIT.
So cities-- when we talk
about agglomeration benefits--
I know we've heard that.
But cities bring together
health care, education, jobs,
and people.
And so when you
live in a place that
has a high concentration
of these things,
you have more access
to those things
than if you were
to live outside.
And that's true for people.
It's also true for businesses.
A business that is looking
to hire talented people
from universities and have
access to, say, airports
and other businesses that
provide services to them
are more likely to find
that in a big city.
So this is part of what's
fueling these trends.
And in big cities, we
also have a problem
because of the high
densities of high traffic.
So if you're looking at
traveling by private auto,
you're going to have congestion.
And in that setting with high
densities and high traffic,
public transportation becomes
more competitive of a mode.
But we also have to consider
the negative aspects
of public transportation from
the passenger's perspective.
You have to wait.
It doesn't pick you
up at your door.
And it doesn't take you right
to the doorstep of where
you're going to.
So it's these tradeoffs.
And when there is enough
traffic and the densities
are sufficiently high,
then public transportation
can become very competitive
from a personal decision-making
standpoint.
In the US, going back
to the US context--
and this comes from
the APTA Fact Book.
They publish this
every few years.
And they always-- so this
is the 2015 publication
for two years before that.
So with data from the American
Community Survey from 2013.
And if we rank the
sort of largest US
cities and metropolitan
areas really by size
and then we look at
their transit mode share,
this is what we get.
So the biggest one,
by far, in the US
is the New York
metropolitan area.
And right below that, we have
San Francisco, Washington,
Boston, Chicago, Philadelphia.
And then you start seeing a
decrease and a pretty rapid
decrease in the
percent of workers
in those metropolises that use
transit to commute to work.
So the question is, why is
the mode share so much higher
for these first few cities?
What do those cities
have in common
that the cities below
them don't have?
AUDIENCE: They have
an old rail structure.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: OK,
so that's a good idea.
Yeah.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: I mean, they have
very, very high population
densities.
New York is like 70,000
people per square mile
and Dallas is
probably like three.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: OK.
AUDIENCE: They have
expensive downtown parking.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Yes.
Other ideas?
AUDIENCE: They're
all older cities.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: And it's
also related to the fact
that you have older systems.
So in fact, those first few--
those first six that I've
mentioned, say New York
through Philadelphia--
are the oldest
systems in the US.
DC is newer.
That's right.
But most of the ones below them
are newer, even newer than DC.
So these are cities that
had an urban fabric that
was created and
developed and densified
before the US road
infrastructure was developed
as it is today.
And therefore, the densities
developed at a higher level.
And they already had
public transportation
serving those sort of OD
pairs in those cities.
So it's sort of a
cyclical virtuous
cycle that sort of makes
public transportation
at those places more
efficient and more
competitive than
the private auto.
Any questions about that?
If we look at so the
transit share modal split
for home-to-work journeys,
this is a little older.
This is a study
that was completed
with data from the year 2000.
And we have different
numbers here.
But I just want to focus on
these five biggest public
transportation
systems or big cities.
And we see the mode share
in each of them for a car
and for transit in 2000
and transit in 2013.
So we can see that, although
in Chicago it mostly
has stayed around the
same, in New York and San
Francisco and Washington and
Boston, it has increased.
So there's been an increase
in the transit mode share.
Population has increased
in these cities
and so has the public
transportation mode share.
In terms of public
transportation funding.
So how will these systems
that are expensive to run
get funded--
and expensive to
build get funded?
So the first thing to note
is that, in North America,
there's a tradition of
dividing the expenses
and the expenditures of
public transportation
into capital expenditures
and operational expenditures.
That's not true
elsewhere in the world.
But it is in North America.
So when we talk about
capital expenditures,
we're talking about
building new systems,
extending systems,
procuring new vehicles,
rolling stock, repairs,
and things like that.
Operating expenses
are what you used
to pay salaries of
drivers, pay for energy
or fuel to propel the
vehicles forward, et cetera.
So another thing to
note is that, if we
look at operating expenses
for example, about a third
of the operating expenses
are covered by fares.
So when you use
the system and you
pay for it and you pay your
$2 or whatever it costs,
you're only paying
for about a third
of what it costs the system to
provide that journey for you
on average.
It does vary from
system to system.
And in some parts of the world,
these numbers are different.
When we talk about local, state,
and federal support or funding,
this all comes
from tax revenues.
So this could be sales
tax, especially when we're
talking about local and state,
and federal taxes, mostly
income taxes.
In terms of capital
expenditures,
what I want to highlight
is that the federal support
is quite high, more than 40%.
And that's much higher
for capital expenditures
than it is for
operating expenditures.
What would that encourage
if you're a state
or you're an agency
and you're operating
a public transportation agency
and you get a lot of subsidy
from the federal level--
so not necessarily
your constituents
for capital expenditures, but
not operating expenditures.
What would that
encourage you to do?
AUDIENCE: Build more
and maintain less?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Build
more and maintain less.
That's exactly right.
So remember I said
earlier there's
been a lot of new builds
in the last 25 years
and a of major repairs
in the last 20 years?
This is why, because there's
a lot of federal support
for doing those projects.
And unfortunately, you
build a bigger system
and you have to now run it.
And that comes from
operating expenses,
which are not as
strongly supported
by the federal government.
So that also hints at
maybe why the industry
is where it is in terms
of state of grid repair.
What influences these trends?
First one, and the very
obvious, is the suburbanization
of homes, employment,
and attractors.
People moving away from
cities to lower dense areas.
Because property is cheaper
and parking might be free.
In America, low costs for
car ownership and operation.
So we have low fuel
taxes in comparison
to other parts of the world and
low taxes when you buy cars.
There is an extensive
urban road infrastructure
that is much higher than it is
in other parts of the world.
And there are many
government policies
that sort of support the road
construction and maintenance
and the use of roads and
the private automobile
and not necessarily
to the same extent
support public transportation.
These include things
like tax benefits
that you can take on your
return, parking requirements
when there is new
construction that, again,
support the private auto.
If we look at
suburbanization just
focusing on the first point and
looking at the same data set
I talked about earlier,
the 2000 journey to work,
we have different numbers here.
But what I really want to
focus on is we have here--
this is like an OD matrix
but by part of the city.
So if you live in the
central city or a suburb
and you work in the
central city or suburb,
what percent of total trips
are covered by each mode?
So we see that we have about 27%
of trips are from central city
to central city.
And about 20% are from the
suburbs to the central city,
so people commuting inbound to
the central business district
in the traditional sense.
Then there's the reverse
commuters, about 9%,
who are living in
the central city
and commuting outbound
into the suburbs.
And then there is
the suburb to suburb,
people who live in the suburb
and work in the suburb,
not necessarily in
the same suburb.
OK, so that's interesting.
That's how the trips are made.
What happens if we
look at the increase?
What are the trends from 1990 to
2000 leading to these numbers?
Well, by far, the
biggest increase
was in suburb-to-suburb
commutes.
And if we look at the public
transportation mode share,
if you live in the city and work
in the city, about 14% of trips
are covered, are made by
public transportation.
It's lower.
It's about 6% if you're
going to or from the suburb.
And it's much lower, 2%,
if you live in the suburbs
and work in the suburbs.
So if you just focus
on three numbers here.
43% of trips are from
a suburb to a suburb.
The trend is that
suburb-to-suburb trips
are increasing.
And that is the
hardest thing to serve
with public transportation.
Why is that?
Why is it difficult
to serve those trips
with public transportation?
AUDIENCE: Low density?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ:
Why is low density--
why does that make it
difficult to serve--
AUDIENCE: Because then it's--
people that need
access to stations,
they're not [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Well, you
could put more service.
You could put more bus
stops and stations.
So--
AUDIENCE: But then
there's not enough people
to take it to make it
financially viable.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Exactly.
So did you hear that?
So because you have
low densities--
you have a sparse OD matrix,
as we say in transportation.
You have fewer
people that are going
from any particular origin to
any particular destination.
When you don't have
those critical densities,
it becomes very expensive
and very inefficient
to deploy resources to
move a lot of people
when the demand for moving a
lot of people is not there.
On the other hand, when you
have dense corridors along which
many people want to move, you do
develop this competitive demand
pattern that is very well
served by public transportation.
And it's very correlated with
whether you are in the suburbs
or in the central city because
central cities are denser.
And there are dense [INAUDIBLE]
corridors in the city,
and also from suburbs
to the center.
Any questions about this?
AUDIENCE: How would you--
I guess you wouldn't consider
something like Uber pool
to be covered by this.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: No.
This excludes things like
the transportation network
companies.
This is traditional
public transportation.
Yeah.
OK, let's look at a few
images, some GIS charts that
were prepared by
Mikel Murga who used
to work in the transit lab.
And he's an expert in modeling.
Here's Boston.
And what we have, let's
go back to the key here.
It's based on the
census data from 2010.
And red means car.
Orange is carpooling.
So that might include this.
Or it might include you
dropping someone off.
Blue will be public
transportation.
And walking will be green.
So this is the center
of Boston right here.
MIT is right here.
This big green area where a
lot of people walk, that's us.
That's MIT.
The center of Boston right here.
So lots of green, lots
of people walking.
Lots of people who start
their trips there and are
going into Boston are also
taking public transportation.
You see a lot of blue.
But as you start moving out of
that center, you get more red.
So this is supports what
we just talked about.
There are lower densities
outside of the central business
district and this
denser Cambridge area
right here, big university
centers, hospitals,
and financial district.
So outside, there
are lower densities.
And there's also a lower supply
of public transportation.
So therefore, most of the
commutes are made by car.
And therefore, you see more red.
You do see some places though
where there's a lot of green
or a lot of blue.
And usually, the they are
close to a commuter rail line.
So if you follow,
the rail lines,
you'll see that,
along those corridors,
there is a bigger share of blue.
The same story in other cities--
Manhattan, of course,
being the biggest provider
of public transportation
and the city
with the most split for
public transportation.
A lot of green in
South Manhattan.
A lot of blue right
around Manhattan.
But as you start
moving out, then you
start getting a lot more red.
Same thing, just more intense.
And then here's Chicago.
Here's Chicago.
Same thing.
City center is right here.
So you can sort of spot
the city center of the city
by how people do their journeys.
Along the lake
coast, you see a lot
of trips made with
public transportation.
But as you start moving
out, especially away
from any rail lines
because, along rail lines,
you'll see some percent of
people taking commuter rail
into Chicago.
OK, so any questions about
this, this picture of mode split
and how it changes
depending on where you are
and where you're
starting your trip
and when you're
ending your trip?
No?
OK.
So here in the US, coming
back, especially to the North
American context, we
have our car road system.
So very highly developed,
more than in other parts
of the world.
Many people own cars.
There are 600 cars for
every 1,000 people.
The car usage is high.
If you look at the--
it's 10,000 vehicle kilometers
per person per year.
Compared to other countries,
we have lower taxes,
lower fees, lower user charges.
So sales taxes are 5% to 8%.
Users pay for only about 60%
of the road infrastructure.
That comes from tolls
and from gas taxes.
The fuel taxes here in
the US are 10% to 20%
of what they are in Europe.
So it gives you an
idea of where we are
and why our policies
encourage owning a car
and operating a car.
Parking is another big one.
I already mentioned this.
So the parking supply
in most of the US
is free and widely available.
So there are 380 parking spaces
per 1,000 central city workers
in the 10 largest cities.
Outside of that,
it's much higher.
Everybody can park.
About 95% of car commuters
enjoy free parking.
So if it doesn't cost you to own
a car or to operate it and you
can park free-- you can leave
your piece of metal doing
nothing and taking up real
estate in a city with no cost--
then you might go
ahead and do that.
So it's a highly developed
urban road system.
We have more roads,
wider roads, longer roads
than in other
parts of the world,
especially if we compare Europe.
And we're talking here about
the 10 largest cities in the US.
We're not talking
about rural areas.
What do people say when
they're advocating for transit?
What are the
traditional arguments
put forth for transit
being good and therefore
we should support transit,
we should fund transit?
The equity is a big one.
So access for people who cannot
drive or choose not to drive.
So we're talking about
elderly, handicapped,
children who can't
drive, poor people
who can't afford to
buy their own car
or to use modes like
Uber, for example.
So that's the equity argument.
And that's a very
sound argument.
Congestion.
So people say put
public transportation
to alleviate congestion.
That's not such a good argument
because lots of the studies
that we've looked at,
even when a lot of people
do take public transportation
when a new system is put in,
the capacity released
in the streets
is usually very quickly.
They demand it again.
So that is not a very
effective method, by itself,
for reducing congestion.
If you tie it to other things
like parking taxes or parking
caps or tolls, then
with a combination
of an increase in public
transportation supply
and an increase in cost or
disutility for taking the car,
you can have an
impact on congestion.
Land use.
So if you want a
nicer, walkable city,
then you should have
public transportation.
If you're driving your
car from home to work,
you're not going to stop.
You're going to work.
And so when you're taking
public transportation
and you stop along
dense corridors
and you probably won't get
dropped off immediately
where you're going to so you
might have to walk by stores
and by restaurants,
that's going to generate
commercial activity.
And it's going to support a land
use that is of nicer quality
than the car might do by itself.
Environmental.
So if people say, let's put
public transportation in
because it's good
for the environment.
Well, it turns out
that actually it's
more effective to work
on the car technology--
hybrid cars, fuel efficiency.
It's a much more effective way
to help the environment just
because so many people drive.
The mode split is so much.
It's about 80% for a car.
It makes a bigger dent to
work on car energy efficiency.
Same with energy.
It has to do with
the same things.
OK, other arguments.
So economic expenditures
for private autos
may be used to improve local
economies and quality of life.
So we say we subsidize
the private auto.
Because people, through
their user fees,
are only paying for
about 60% of the costs.
The remaining cost is
coming from tax revenue that
could have been spent on
nicer cities and nicer
public transportation systems.
And then there's the
agglomeration benefits.
If you want to increase
the economic activity
and the socioeconomic
welfare of a city,
then you can put in
transit because it
supports higher densities.
So how would New York and
Boston and San Francisco
be or have developed
if they didn't
have their public transportation
systems right now?
They really would be nothing
like they are right now.
If you took Manhattan and
shut down all the metros--
and we've had these real-life
experiments when hurricanes
come around--
the city shuts down.
You can't commute into the
city without these systems.
There is not enough
capacity on the roads
to bringing all those people
in and to support that economy.
So there is a benefit to
having these systems in.
But because these investments
were made sometimes
a century ago, nobody
is talking about
or quantifying the benefit in
assigning it to that system.
So the contribution of
earlier investments,
especially in heavy rail,
is not being valued.
That has changed a
little bit recently.
So when London was doing
its economic analysis
for Crossrail, a big metro
system across the city,
they did say, we
need a long view.
This is going to have benefits
lasting many, many decades.
We're not looking at
a 20, 30-year horizon.
We're looking at
way beyond that.
We want London to prosper
and to become more dense
and to have higher
agglomeration benefits.
So other arguments
are that transit
decreases the external costs
of transportation in cities.
So when we look at
things like accidents,
you're less likely to be
to get into an accident
if you're in a bus than
if you are driving a car.
Impacts on human health.
Any clue about what
I mean by that?
AUDIENCE: Walking.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Yeah.
Walking.
So you walk a little more.
Yeah.
There's the impact of if
you have a lot of traffic
and you're sort of
sitting in traffic,
you're breathing in dirty air.
So if that's the case,
pollution kills people slowly
but at a higher rate than
accidents and other things.
So these are the
impacts on human health.
And I did say earlier that
public transportation by itself
is not going to address that.
But if you pair it
with some policy that
will curb the private auto
demand and reduce emissions,
then you can have an
impact on health care,
healthier costs from
the government side
and the human health for people.
So again, congestion, noise.
We can reduce the noise
of cars on streets.
And climate change,
global warming.
Here's a nice picture of public
transportation catalyzing
sort of the urban fabric.
So making cities
more walkable just
to highlight what
we said earlier.
Critical assessment.
So we've stabilized public
transport in North America.
We saw that, in
the 1990s, we had
an increase in the
mode share of auto
and a decrease in public
transport and walking
and biking.
And now, that's starting
to come back up.
There are many new rail
initiatives like Phoenix,
Denver, and Salt Lake City.
And they are successful.
And especially if we look at
older systems like New York
City but also at some of the
not-so-old ones like Houston
and Seattle, we see
very successful systems
that are being
heavily used and are
contributing to nicer land use
and developing the economy.
Institutional change is
occurring very slowly, maybe
too slowly.
Many things are changing
in terms of technology,
in terms of policy,
in terms of what
the private sector is offering.
And the public sector
is not catching up.
It's not moving as quickly.
So another challenge is the
retention of political support.
So yes, question here.
AUDIENCE: This is
just North America?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: This is
focusing in North America.
AUDIENCE: Because
China, for example,
is building a crazy
amount of [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ:
But they also have
a big increase in private auto.
So both things are happening.
So retention of political
support is another challenge.
So just keeping everyone happy
and having those stakeholders
in a political
constituency happy enough
to support you and
not try to defund
the public
transportation sector.
Especially-- that's critical
if public interpretation
is much better at serving
the most dense corridors
and you're only
benefiting people there.
And people from, for example,
the rest of the state
don't see a direct benefit.
But they're putting sales
tax into that system.
That's a tricky
thing politically.
So that's another challenge.
So we expect to see continued
growth in the periphery.
So suburbanization.
Health care is getting better.
So the percent of people
that are old and can't drive
is going up.
And so that might
mean that we might
need more public transport.
Technology is changing.
Telecommunications is
advancing rapidly now
with all the internet of
things and sensors everywhere.
We do get a lot of data.
And we can start using that
data to plan better systems
and to analyze how
people are using them.
And we'll get to that
later in this course.
The public has a
higher expectation.
Because you have a
smartphone and you
can know where the
bus is, you sort of
are more aware of the system.
And you might start to demand
higher quality service.
And if other parts of the world
or other systems are doing it
and mine isn't, then I'm
starting to expect that--
I know about it because we
share all of this information
through YouTube
and the internet.
So I want the same
thing in my city.
And I want the same
thing in my system.
And then finally--
and this is very
recent-- the transportation
network company.
So the likes of Uber and
Lyft are making a dent
on the demand and
the mobile split.
So this is somewhere in between
where it's not your own auto
and you're paying for something.
You might be carpooling so
in some sense it's public,
but not really.
So the other challenge
here is that a lot of these
are startups that are heavily
funded by venture capital.
And they are spending more
money than they can make
through their fair revenues.
So it's not clear how that will
play out as the years go by
and if they can
keep their prices
and remain as competitive.
So ingredients for
future success.
So again, speaking of the
political constituencies,
maintaining a
supportive coalition.
So making sure that you
expand that base of people
who benefit from
public transport
and make the case that,
even if you're not directly
using public transportation, it
has economic benefit for you.
So that's necessary if we want
to move forward, especially
with the government funding
local and state taxes
for example for
public transportation.
Expand the definition
of public transport.
There is now a greater
variety of services
and more flexibility.
And public
transportation systems
are starting to consider
different vehicle sizes
and partnering with
transportation network
companies to achieve
higher efficiencies
and just target their
supply to particular demands
and densities.
A greater involvement
of the private sector.
So the use of transportation
network companies
is one example.
But also partnerships
with the private sector
to operate bus service, so
public private partnerships.
And innovative financing
and procurement techniques
for construction of new
lines or operations.
Aggressive implementation
of new technology.
So now, again, I said,
more sensors, more data,
better information provision.
Tell your customers, your
passengers where the vehicles
are, what the reliability is.
Make more effective decisions
like real-time operations
control to keep your system
operating as you planned it.
We'll have an entire election
on real-time control later on.
And you can improve your vehicle
designs-- so all these things,
right?
So when I refer to
improve vehicle design,
we'll talk more about
this in the next lecture.
We have cleaner technologies,
more fuel efficient,
more quiet.
So technology can be used
to improve the experience.
And then there's the
organizational change.
So that needs to happen.
And the public sector is a
little slow in this regard.
So greater operating staff
responsibility, accountability.
In many agencies, we have the
problem that it's not clear
who is responsible for what.
And so whenever
some decision has
to be made, who do you
go to get that signature?
Who approves it?
You have to talk
to several people
in different departments.
And it just gets slow.
So even for the simple
things, and sometimes
especially for simple
things, it's a little slow.
So also increased
customer orientation.
There's a culture, especially
in the more traditional
public transportation
agencies, that you run service.
And you don't really think
about people and serving people
as if they were your customers.
But that's changing.
Some agencies, the most
cutting-edge agencies,
are really treating
people as their customers
and doing marketing and reaching
out to their customer base
to run surveys, understand
what makes them unhappy,
use that information to
make better decisions
to respond to the feedback.
So that's the end of my
introductory presentation.
We're done a little early,
which is fine because today
is the first lecture.
So if you have questions about
any of what we talked about,
please let me know.
You might want to ask
that question right now so
that other people can benefit.
But if not, you can also just
come to me and we can chat.
Yeah, so.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you want to say a
few words about the assignment
1?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Sure.
Well, I already
did a little bit.
So it's an introduction
to cyclical transportation
systems.
So your first task is to
go out and go into Stellar.
And I'm doing this on purpose.
I want to make sure that
you have access to Stellar
because we're going
to be using that.
So go to Stellar.
Look at the reading.
The reading is
very introductory.
And it introduces you to the
idea of cycle time and headway
and all these things.
And that's how you
think as an engineer
of planning a public
transportation system
and determining how many
vehicles you need to operate
a service and the impact
of running time variability
on your system and the cost.
So we're just getting our feet
wet with a very simple example.
And I've generated
some data that you'll
be analyzing in a very
step-by-step fashion
to sort of guide you
through that process.
Later on in the
semester, you're going
to get real data, which is not
going to be as nicely laid out.
And you're going to have a more
challenging task of actually
planning service
using real data.
So this is an opportunity to get
the concepts sort of ingrained
and make sure you master
them before you tackle
the more challenging
task of doing it
with real data on
a messier situation
but on a more
realistic situation.
AUDIENCE: How do you
wish that we submit it?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: On Stellar.
I don't want any
paper submissions.
The other thing is--
so yeah.
Please save your files as PDF
and upload them to Stellar.
So the preferred
format would be PDF.
And the other thing you can do
for this one is a spreadsheet.
So if you want, you can
work on a spreadsheet.
And just please be very clear
about here's question 1.
And lay it out clearly
for me and explain.
There's some explanation.
Don't just plug and chug.
Please explain your logic.
A few sentences suffice.
But explain why you
chose to do this
and what your calculations mean.
And you can just send me the
spreadsheet instead of the PDF
if you want.
And that could help because
I can see your work.
All right.
He had a question.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Yeah, this is sort
of a semantic thing.
When you said the success
of the Houston system,
what were you suggesting there?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ: Well, I mean,
demand has gone up, right?
There are many ways of measuring
the success of a system.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
your bus system
or is it that they
built a rail system?
Or--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ:
Just in general.
I mean, it's a system
that was put in.
And yeah, it could
be more successful.
But people are using it.
And it's having some
impact on the city.
And it's visible.
So any other questions?
All right.
Class dismissed.